9 mysteriöse lichtpunkte am himmel
bereiten fachleuten weltweit
kopfzerbrechen denn diese neuen simultan
auftauchenden lichtpunkte sind nur auf
einer einzigen astronomischen aufnahme
aus dem jahr 1950 zu sehen klar scheint
bei diesen neuen lichtpunkten handelt es
sich weder um bekannte objekte noch um
störquellen jetzt hat ein schwedisches
forschungsteam diese mysteriösen
himmelsphänomene genauer untersucht und
die erklärung die übrig bleibt ist mind
blowing klicks um sunsim future hier
gibt's drei mal pro woche spannende
science videos abonniert den kanal und
aktiviert die glocke nur so verpasst ihr
nichts los geht's
herzlich willkommen
diese objekte auf einer 70 jahre alten
foto platte gehören wohl mit zu den
spannendsten detektivgeschichten der
astronomie denn diese lichtpunkte sind
nur auf einer einzigen himmels aufnahme
vom zwölften april 1950 zu sehen sowohl
in früheren als auch in späteren
aufnahmen sind diese stellen leer trotz
intensiver forschung ist es astronomie
teams weltweit bislang nicht gelungen
eine erklärung für diese rätselhafte
objekte zu finden als ursache für diese
aufgenommenen lichter konnten in
vergangenen analysen sowohl
astronomische objekte als auch
störquellen oder gängige kontaminationen
ausgeschlossen werden es müssen also
sterne oder irgend etwas ähnliches sein
doch worum handelt es sich dann bei
diesen licht geben ein schwedisches
forschungsteam hat den fraglichen
himmels ausschnitt noch einmal genauer
ins visier genommen und sich auf die
suche nach möglichen erklärungen gemacht
in dieser aktuellen studie werden auch
exotischere erklärungsmöglichkeiten in
betracht gezogen wie etwa
außerirdische zivilisation sind diese
etwa für das verschwinden dieser sterne
verantwortlich könnten es also
raumschiffe oder beißen sphären seien
riesige raumstation rund um sterne die
ihre energie absorbieren können sterne
überhaupt von einem auf den anderen
moment verschwinden alle spannenden
infos zum geheimnis der neuen
verschwundenen sterne gibt es jetzt hier
bei tricks und stunts
klar ist sterne entstehen und vergehen
um zudem schwanken sie auch in ihrer
helligkeit doch vor allem ferne sonnen
gehören zu den konstanten unseres
sternenhimmels prozesse diese verändern
könnten wirken nämlich extrem
langfristig auf der anderen seite gibt
es im kosmos zahlreiche prozesse die
einen himmelskörper forum beginnt
aufleuchten und dann wieder erlöschen
lassen strahlen ausbrüche von schwarzen
löchern supernovae oder kometen manches
davon dauert nur wenige sekunden
andere prozesse sind sogar über jahre
nachweisbar doch was steckt jeweils
dahinter diese frage können
wissenschaftlerinnen und wissenschaftler
beispielsweise anhand der form des
lichtspektrums oder der dauer solcher
beobachtungen beantworten nicht jedoch
bei einem phänomen das auf einer
astronomischen foto platte vor rund 70
jahren festgehalten wurde ein astronomie
team hatte am zwölften april 1950 9
lichtpunkte auf einer aufnahme
festgehalten bereits eine halbe stunde
später und seitdem nie wieder waren
diese lichtpunkte nicht mehr zu
beobachten die aufnahme gelang im rahmen
der panama sky survey eine der
wichtigsten fotografischen
durchmusterung des nördlichen und
äquatorialen himmels in der zweiten
hälfte des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts das
teleskop in paloma observatorien in
südkalifornien hatte diese lichtquellen
aufgenommen die aufnahme zeigt einen 10
x 10 bogen minuten großen himmels
ausschnitt zu sehen sind zum einen die
bekannten sterne und andere
himmelsobjekte zum anderen zeigt sie
aber auch einige nicht identifizierbare
lichtpunkte konkret handelt es sich
dabei um 8 runde punkte die stern
ähnlich wirken zudem ein möglicherweise
leicht länglicher fleck alle objekte
tauchen verstreut auf der foto platte
auf und genau das verwundert auch das
schwedische forschungsteam um die
astronomen wer tritt will er all diese
quellen sind weder in einer 30 minuten
früher gemachten aufnahmen noch in einem
sechs tage später erstellten foto zu
sehen auch spätere aufnahmen die von
anderen teleskopen gemacht wurden zeigen
diese neuen lichter nicht mehr bereits
vor zwei jahren
2009/10 hatten die astronomen astronom
mit ihrer analyse im rahmen des
projektes kogon weskow steht für
vanishing point sources hewing es
century of operations und inhaltlich
geht es um rund 100 ereignisse
verschwunden sterne also 100 objekte
sind in den 100 jahren in denen wir den
himmel genauer beobachten verschwunden
ist das puky oder etwas ganz normales
rund 600 millionen himmelsobjekte hatte
das internationale forschungsteam um die
astrophysikerin beatrix will für ihre
analyse genauer untersucht diese
ergebnisse wurden dann mit den daten aus
dem katalog des panzers also dem
panoramic server teleskop und rapid
response system verglichen dabei dann
die überraschung in dem alten sternen
katalog spürten die fachleute
150 tausend objekte auf für die es in
ihrem aktuellen himmels atlas keine
entsprechung haben diese mysteriösen
anomalien untersuchte das forschungsteam
dann genauer mit einem kuriosen ergebnis
demnach konnten 100 besonders
interessante quellen identifiziert
werden bei dem vergleich mit den sternen
aufnahmen aus den 50er jahren fielen den
wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftlern also 100 objekte ins
auge die in dieser kurzen zeit einfach
von der bildfläche oder besser gesagt
vom himmel verschwunden sind wow das ist
schon ziemlich verrückt in ihrer
aktuellen studie hat das forschungsteam
um beatrix will nun noch einmal diesen
bestimmten himmels ausschnitt in dem die
neuen verschwundenen sterne aufgetaucht
waren ins visier genommen die große
frage immer noch dieselbe welche
ereignisse oder objekte kommen als
ursache in frage die position der neuen
lichtpunkt verglichen sie zudem noch
einmal mit aktuellen himmels aufnahmen
dieses gebiets das gran canarias
teleskop nutzen sie zudem auch um diesen
himmels ausschnitt selbst noch einmal zu
untersuchen doch wieder dasselbe
ergebnis die sterne bleiben verschwunden
lediglich für zwei lichtquellen konnten
optische gegenstücke aufgespürt werden
die sich in der nähe befinden doch zu
dem kurzen und möglicherweise einmaligen
aufleuchten der mysteriösen alten
lichtpunkte aus dem 150 passen sie
dennoch nicht dazu heißt es in der
aktuellen studie ein cluster von sehr
fernen galaxien könnte zwar das
vorübergehende aufleuchten erklären aber
dies müsste auch nach den 1950 er jahren
noch anhalten die fachleute bestätigen
in ihrem aktuellen aufsatz noch einmal
dass es sich bei den verschwundenen
stern keinesfalls um meteore oder
asteroiden fragmente handeln kann da
sich fragmente eines soliden oder
meteoriten sehr schnell bewegen und der
erde nahe sind müssen sie in der foto
platte von damals die 50 minuten lang
belichtet wurde als längliche
leuchtspuren auftauchen sind es also
möglicherweise kosmischen staubkörnern
die in unserer atmosphäre verglüht sind
aber auch das passt einfach nicht und
wird vom schwedischen forschungsteam
verneint denn zwar können kosmischen
staubkörnern kurz aufblitzen bevor sie
verdampfen doch solche blitze wären viel
zu licht schwach als dass sie mit dem
teleskop von damals aufgenommen hätten
werden können das fazit von beatrix
wieder roll- und ihrem team die tatsache
dass wir hier neuen simultan
auftauchende transiente haben passt
damit zu keiner bekannten natürlichen
erklärung passen würden allerdings
satelliten blitzer kurze lichtblitze
entstehen wenn die sonnensegel oder
reflektierenden außenwände von
satelliten von der sonne angestrahlt
werden doch fakt ist sputnik 1 der erste
künstliche satellit der die umlaufbahn
erreichen startete im januar 257 sieben
jahre nachdem also die foto platte
entstanden ist also leitet dieses
erklärung auch aus es bleibt ehrlich
gesagt nicht mehr viel übrig außer ja
bereits vor zwei jahren hat er das
forschungsteam selbst nicht ausschließen
können dass außerirdische zivilisation
für das mysteriöse verschwinden dieser
insgesamt ja 100 sterne verantwortlich
sein könnten demnach seien solche zitat
beobachtungen wie diese eine
herausforderung für die astrophysik
handelte sich bei dem verschwundenen
sternen also möglicherweise um die
sogenannten tysons wären dabei handelt
es sich um theoretisch beschriebene
strukturen hohlkugeln die einen stern
umhüllen und so dessen gesamte energie
absorbieren falls man solch eine dyson
sphäre aufspüren könnte wäre dass
tatsächlich ein beweis für
außerirdisches leben das intelligent
hoch entwickelt ist mit solch einer
dyson sphäre die einen stern komplett
umschließt und so seine ganze energie
absorbiert oder umlenkt ließen sich
planetensysteme beschleunigen somit
könnte man der ausdehnung des alls
entgehen und in eine andere richtung
fliegen oder sind es gar methodische
mängel durch die diese mysteriösen
lichtpunkte auf der foto platte
entstanden sind das forschungsteam um
beatrix wieder hat auch diese
möglichkeit noch einmal in betracht
gezogen waren es möglicherweise
staubkörnchen auf den glasplatten des
scanners mit denen die fotoplatten
digitalisiert wurden oder etwa
doppelbelichtung oder winzige
feuchtigkeits töpfchen auf dem foto
platten doch eigentlich müssten solche
steuereffekte mehr spuren hinterlassen
zudem spricht auch die form der
lichtpunkte gegen diese erklärungs
möglichkeit auch diese aktuelle studie
kann also keine finalen antworten auf
all diese offenen fragen geben wie
können dem mysteriösen neuen lichtpunkte
erklärt werden das forschungsteam betont
an dieser stelle noch einmal wie wichtig
es ist die quelle final zu
identifizieren dazu heißt es wir glauben
dass das rätsel um die simultan
transienten eine detektivgeschichte ist
der die astronomische gemeinschaft ihre
aufmerksamkeit schenken sollte sind wir
also einfach zu dumm um das rätsel zu
lösen oder sind es tatsächlich
außerirdische die große frage die die
astrophysik umtreibt und dieses jahr
kommen wir der beantwortung der frage
vielleicht deutlich näher außerirdisches
leben dunkle materie und mehr james webb
weltraumteleskop vor dem start anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren das geht mit
dem abo button unter jedem video kostet
nichts und macht schlau gewiss also was
jetzt zu tun ist
bis dann bleibt dran